that's speaking of Michigan man he
answered the call even though as I read
of prior to this segment his text
response when I asked him to call
nothing
nothing hurts a host more than being
held responsible for the wins and losses
of a team after somebody calls in and
Taylor Lujan was counting Taylor LaJuan
fresh off of the beatdown of the Jaguars
last night from they seven and six
Tennessee Titans here on the show how
are you bud oh good I'm reluctant to be
here but I am I'm even more happy now we
figured out this social media debacle
yes and the phone debacle I love that we
can to me too I'm glad that I've got
direct contact with Taylor Lewan once
again after all that but um and I
appreciate you calling and even so
you're on eggshells right now calling
into this program is what you're saying
I'm a little I'm a little nervous but I
mean I did the whole gibbous national
praise thing before I put my foot in my
mouth this time I'm not saying a word
I'm staying humble moving forward okay
what's it like to watch somebody go 99
yards Taylor oh man I woke up this
morning and I was still just goes to the
old Twitter looking at it and then it's
unbelievable I I think I said last night
that around the 45 yard line I started
to run down there but then I went down
Marcus and we were both just and all
like that is it's truly the the best
it's easily the best thing I've ever
been a part of but it may be the best
thing I've ever seen of all time I think
it'd definitely rivals that that beast
motor on it that guy he works so hard
every single day it's amazing to see
like you know all that success he had
last night I was happy to be a part of
it you know and just watching it it the
number of times he shoved people off of
him but normally when people get you
know when running back shove people off
of them they kind of stop running and he
kind of kept gaining ten yards every
time he kept stepping and then suddenly
oh my god that's the end zone that seats
in front of I couldn't believe that I
was unreal I I think at one point he
literally stopped sort of running back
towards where we started the play is
just to stiff arm a couple more guys
just beginning I know how to get it and
then he kept so what was it like on the
sidelines after that I mean would you
would you say when you because
again this has only happened once before
a run that long Taylor III actually had
no idea like I mean I knew 99 I knew
there's literally no there's no further
of a distance you can go but uh I
honestly I was off field goal the next
that next plane so we came off and I
mean everyone was everyone was
electrostatic we're having a good time
we were actually talking about it before
that play we're like we need we need
this go 99 honestly I brought up the
team I was like we need to do what
Houston did to us two weeks ago and and
take this thing in one play and go house
and quarterback came in and he called
there if he called a quarterback sneak
to a check of the play we actually was I
thought to myself well a quarterback
sneaks definitely not going to get us 99
and he checked it and the rest is
history man he killed it
so no kidding the call was for Mariota
just to get some breathing room and said
he'd call a check to the play that 99
yards later it's it's a touchdown
oh yeah I mean I think when you get into
those type of situations adhesively you
just want to get enough room for that
punter to to get so he like totally
backed up to make it an easy block I
know we had one the week before and
that's kind of the mindset when you get
the one you need to get yourself some
breathing room and you keep it going
keep her going but I mean I'll take that
99 touchdown on any day of the week
lolani around the Rich Eisen sure later
on I'm gonna play the the the Monday
Night Football call way before you were
born in 1983 of the Dorsett called and
and if Danny Don Meredith joked as folks
will hear that Dorsett cuz it was like
think of us as one of those first runs
of the night he's like he could go for a
hundred yards tonight is what dandy Don
said and interestingly enough I mean he
kept running you guys kept pounding it
with Derek Henry 238 yards when it is
all said and done is this something we
should expect from your team over the
next three weeks as you try and make the
playoffs in the chilly months of
December Taylor I think I think it'd be
unhealthy to to raise the expectations
to franchise setting records every
single game but I don't believe that
this is the markers pulled us over and a
half we came and said tell us this is
the standard this is what
it needs to be about and every single we
need to act like we've been there and I
think this office lines caught a lot of
flack this year some of those guys have
cut a lot a lot of heat and for them to
come out and to do what they did and I
mean I'm just happy and proud to be a
part of it and I think we got three more
games and we know if we win those three
games is a big chance we can make the
playoffs so I think everyone's eyes are
set on this next game against the organ
moving forward and hoping for the best
man but I think that should definitely
be running the football effectively will
win you games but it opens up the pass
see they start stacking the bollocks
more I mean the safety start biting a
little bit more on those two actions we
got the burglars outside with taewon
Cory and tolerate I can just get going
and it's it's a it's impressive madam
I'm just very happy interesting what you
just said there Taylor LaJuan cuz you
know mariota's rep is as a man of few
words did he say stuff like that to you
guys often just like pulling you guys
aside and say hey boys is the standard
and not often I think what's the old
term speak softly bacteria basement
that's definitely that's definitely his
imoen you know I just I got so much
respect for that guy he just regardless
of what in the outside outside outside
noises he he just used pressing hoard
and keeps going man I had this I never
played with a quarterback quite like him
he's a he's unbelievable guy so before I
let you go tailor into your your
tennessee afternoon there what was that
sequence with the Jalen Ramsey about
where he just went down was that all
about
we hit download the three yard line or
whatever and she comes up and makes a
play and just start slicing his little
muscles and so it's constant
I just ran over there like here's our
down 21 points in the fourth
probably best to just be quiet and get
back and he does the most theatrics of
all NBA flops I've ever seen in my
entire life and I don't know why it is
busted out the violin playing a mess -
they strolled off back to Jacksonville
busted out the old fin or I guess whose
were in Nashville is that what that was
thought that you were just like you know
Crimea River that's the way I took it
sort of like the Crimea River that was
the point that was definitely the point
I tell you what if I took one class of
violin class one time and it sound like
scratching that's what I never come on
now Taylor Luanne's taking a violin
class one was at high school middle
school what was that you know when
you're in class they bring out those
annoying salutes in elementary school
sure another one's playing it just
sounded like trailer trash everywhere
and they kind of gave us an opportunity
I'm gonna try to play the violin no but
yeah give it a shot you know eight year
old a lot of ambition so I just want to
see the world one violin at a time and
it didn't work out for me I had to go
like a different different arrangement
of a journey and I end up being a
football player it's good well speaking
of it
speaking of not working out Taylor
before I let you go day after the big
game I go to work I don't know if you
were watching NFL Network that morning
at all probably not you'd probably get
ready for your game but man did I just
take it in the chops from Mariucci and
Kurt Warner they were just absolutely
hammering me about Michigan's loss to
Ohio State and I can only imagine though
those guys didn't even go to Ohio State
your coach did what was it like from
from from Vrabel the day after Michigan
lost Aloha State for you it it really
wasn't the day after that hurt the most
it was during which I was sitting in the
cafeteria at this lone table just me it
was rabl and his secretary stretch who
also in Ohio State and I was just being
graded it was it was a bloodbath it was
real time that you don't want to talk
about losing games that's not the reason
why I came on didn't want to come on
this is the reason I was a fearful
discolor it was tough man that was a
tough one to be a part of to watch but
I'll tell you what the Oilers bowl or
School Peach Bowl that's fruit yes
we can make it work gets Florida I think
we played our rival opponent we played
them every year it seems like so
hopefully we get out get this win Urban
Meyer's retiring couldn't be happier
about if I'm being honest could not be
happier mmm we'll see what happens in
the coming years I think in the old I
think it's really becoming a habit for
Michigan people to say years or a year
but I'm on it I'm on the train next year
were gay I can't believe you were
watching it with Vrabel that that dude
you deserve a medal for that you really
do okay it was it was bad during
practice I'm looking at our video guy
and two people stoned on Anthony get
your phone out and give me scores give
me updates give me updates and he's
telling me and I drop a huge f-bomb in
the middle of practice every time I hurt
them score and then about half down we
came back and we were in the cafeteria
watching man and it was it was tough to
watch and I thought those guys play hard
hey let me be more proud of that team
just wish that W know I know me too
thanks for call brother always enjoy our
chats you the man Congrats on that big w
last night in row grading the way you
and the rest your comrades did for a
Henry and the rest of the team anytime
you take care that's Terrell the 1-800
177 on Twitter the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience